en bolivia se han establecido medidas de
bioseguridad precisas para que los
electores concurran a votar este domingo
protegidos por ejemplo es obligatorio
que todos lleven barbijo además de su
propio bolígrafo para evitar prestarse
uno y el centro de votación el tribunal
supremo electoral además ha dispuesto
dividir a los electores bolivianos en
dos grandes grupos el primero está
compuesto por aquellos cuyo carnet
termina entre el 0 y el 4 y deben votar
en la mañana los demás deben hacerlo en
la tarde además el tribunal supremo
electoral ha dispuesto a aumentar los
recintos electorales para que no existan
aglomeraciones en las filas en todo caso
lo que más preocupa a las autoridades no
es tanto lo que vaya a suceder el día de
la elección sino lo que ha sucedido
previamente los partidos como el
movimiento al socialismo creemos han
realizado concentraciones masivas sin
respetar las normas de bioseguridad y
eso podría generar un rebrote una nueva
ola de coronavirus en el país en todo
caso existe un estudio de la empresa
mercados y muestras que asegura que más
del 60
ciento de la población considera que es
seguro concurrir a votar este domingo y
sólo el 18 diría que es poco seguro